quella sì di ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono va vj e ci siamo dati su ali
e niso lei credo che sia l'ultimo
episodio questo perché chi è questo ha
già altissimo ma ciao bello ma come stai
resta qui ragazzi posso posso dargli
fuoco un'altra vi prego una volta sola
vi supplico prendi della vetta per la
torre shines dovuto a quella linea
capire un attimo c'è un android che
cazzo perché ci sarà bastati android
torna niente prendono fuoco che questo
si è colta torcia umana mi dici dove
vado perché non ancora capito io non ho
ancora capito ragazzi che cosa stiamo
giocando a fare che aliena morto però se
titoli lanciati sono bravo niente dove
brogliano entra che io la prossima il
prossimo compleanno che faccio al posto
delle candeline cazzo voglio lui
praticamente ragazzi l'unica cosa che mi
rimane da fare
unica e trovare quel tizio che mi sa che
che mia gradisce un caffè devo
disattivare sti minchia di android o mio
dio
che figo questa questa sarebbe la tromba
dell'ascensore che figata
non è che mi crolla qualcosa addosso non
ero mica perché ciò giusto un po di kakà
possa andare con ok piano però non
andare avanti che finisce ma ce la posso
fare benissimo sta cosa comunque a parte
fare il tecnico degli ascensori posso
fare qualcosa di utile tipo magari
andare fuori dai che sono già fatta sono
è caduto è caduta una scala e vabbè dai
da dipanare la madonna che cazzo io non
ho fatto niente perché poi sappiamo
com'è che non ti può esserlo del mondo
ho fatto un casino ma va bene facciamo
finta di niente
qualcuno questa cosa me la deve spiegare
[Musica]
la cosa mi arrampicai nelle negli
ascensori mi è una cosa che mi piace
fare riscorso episodio e vado nel mio
assenso di casa mia prova a vedere se
riesco complimenti alla ragazza che ha
battuto aliens è fatta un culo così e
rischia di morire nelle trombe degli
ascensori provare giorno c'è sempre
gente bella in questi posti molto belli
che che sguardo di ecstasy mi fa piacere
questo è vivo lo brucia prescindere laga
e vivo so se avrei scommesso il mondo
proprio di qualche disattivare gli
androidi che figo essere o non essere
questo è bruciare nel dubbio ti brucio
io sono capire un attimo dove televisa
attivo di qua beni posto ci abbiamo
fatto ancora non sto capendo che stiamo
facendo
devi morire l'ho preso ragazzi io devo
farmi luce così abbiate pazienza non
vedo niente
bravo file non c'e zio fi luce branco si
apri apri cazzo si apre lo è sei più
brutto di quanto pensassi
ma [ __ ] è morto è morto sommesso
mezz'ora e poi era questo ti puoi aprire
o mio dio bella roba ragazzi con più che
come ti permetti di chiudere st porto
che è successo ma io uso entro quanto
prima ma questo lo sa che sono cattivi
android la comunicazione diretta con la
quale proprio parlano tranquilli c'è
solo con me ce l'avete stranzi è una
roba tipo in tempo per questo questo è
amore ragazze ci sta e la madonna che
cazzo sei hulk ma serio riuscito a fare
il culo android e non ci possono aiutare
la madonna che cazzo ma veramente seria
ma questo tizio è e hulk è impossibile
devo trovare samuel perché mio dove è
impossibile trova samuel si guarda mia
cagato proprio quando l'ho detto che
qualcuno questa cosa me la deve spiegare
ma che è un robot pure lui e così mi
piace premere i pulsanti rossi anche se
non so che cazzo servono perfetto e
quello si sta guardando il pene se gli
passò attraversa va bene ci provano
ancora capito ragazzetto legno non ha
ancora qui
cazzo fai vai vai vai vai non sapere io
lo sapevo ma ci avrei scommesso
qualsiasi cosa lo sapevo se si è chiuso
si apre di nuovo verso i ragazzi ce
l'abbiamo nel culo mi sa che non passano
adesso sta sto presentimento come non si
vabè passate ma che bella che mi hai che
mi piacciono queste feste si prende
molto ragazzi non è morto non è morto
si va avevano tutti a fuoco ma non
muoiono ok merda merda non ascolta zio
di morire no non regalano avete capito
io vi ammazzo tutti gli ammazzo le
famiglie [ __ ] non muoiono vogliamo
muoio che palle ma serio
sono sette i 700 android vabbè che
stupro è questo ma [ __ ]
morite tutti non posso farcela mai nella
vita
se mi ha lasciato andare che culo vi
ammazzo i parenti pure unite
il crepacuore non c'è non so mai pare
che uno si un andato questo è vivo fuori
è possibile si vabbè dai sono troppi
rega non ce la farò mai nella vita
come va tessera dove è stat estera di
accesso di merda mi date la testata di
accesso spacco la mamma ecco bravo morto
sono a san marino tutti però sono fatti
fuori quasi 6 e trick shot
[Musica]
eccola perfetto non avrei mai allora
doveva ucciderli per forza ok ho paura
di vedere che cosa c'è qua dietro
vincerà il punto di salvataggio giorno
salve ascolta zio no no no no però non
devi essere così solo non so già subito
di qua dai vari rai che li ha portati lì
ha portato veloce però accessi
mettiamoci 45 minuti e non lo so
se mi tocchi denuncio ti denuncio basta
sta merda di android in via di qua non
ce la posso più farlo eh sì ma
[ __ ] [ __ ] è morto non è ma
questi sono diverse sono troppi ma come
faccio se dimmi che possa andare di
sotto si veloce già fatta sì incredibile
perfetto prova a uscire ai ragazzi non
vi prometto niente ma ci provo permesso
se qualcuno ci sono perfetto ma mai mai
mai si no c'è c'è tanto ciò del tempo da
buttare però che so già che mi diceva
che muoio so già che muoio veloce sì mi
stanno più gli stanno sfilacciando lo so
fuori non è vero non li sparo perché
qualcosa che non crepa allora ancora non
ho capito mio dio
ragazzi non ci posso no no no no fermo
ascoltami parlando non puoi fare la tac
in questo momento fai altre cose
la contessina la sua lunga invenzione la
creatura scorrendo mio dio
vabbè pazienza di morire a lui ripresa
ma devo staccare io il cavo ma serio ma
come io sono adesso fare l'elettricista
dove doveva sto cavo rosso di merda che
lo sta morendo là dentro
di qua di qua questo giallorosso questo
caso rosso
vai forza perché solo perché lui è
[ __ ] se non ci sarebbe questo
problema vai l'ho tolto ecco se se lo
vedo non vedo un cazzo però va bene blu
blu blu veloce 9 perché il terreno che
non si vede una sega
ok io non ci posso veramente messo a
fare l'elettricista perché un tizio
delle sei messo in un attacco si
riescono mare bruttissimo
ok ho vinto a me le torte perfetto è
morto non è morto ma quasi
bravo zio bravo perfetto per pet sì sì
sì sei un bel ragazzo
questo succede a prendere a cazzotti
serio
mio dio no raia mi spiace trova davvero
molto io ci ho provato in tutti i modi a
salva non c'è stato verso londra dico
che devo andare di qua anche se non ha
capito devo mettere dove mettere le armi
li veramente ma non ci credono ma ciò 2
miliardi di aria e che poi mi spiegate
come cazzo fa a portare tutte ste armi
una ragazza ci avrei a cena avrei altre
comunque tipo va bene ok conti cazzo
sono state ma le posso prendere amici
che servono in teoria le armi ci sono
gli androidi brutti e cattivi
mi fai passare posso prendere le armi
nord che cazzo sono andate le armi ce
l'abbiamo fatta a sto cazzo
ovviamente devo entrare in apollo e
consultare a qualcosa che sarebbe sta
merda
solo che non ci ho messo anni pro dovuto
fare veloce perché mi piacciono hanno
messo qualcosa un mezzo secoli per
farcela e tipo una navicella spazio tv e
di bellissimo
londra la
oh mio dio cazzo di temere quando queste
cose quando si muovono lei e pavimenti
che io non è che sono esperto di
pavimenti simoni cos'è e tipo
l'enterprise io entra il gioco figo c'è
una webcam che faccio il video c'è di
fumetto non fa un gameplay ho paura di
vedere che cosa diavolo tira fuori prova
bene cos'è fermare gli androidi negativo
c'è verso via priorità su tutto protegge
sempre interrompere le comunicazioni ho
capito vuol dire che è tornato sulla
stazione alienò c'è cosa vuol dire ce
l'ha fatta disattivare stemar degli
androidi non ci dà la parte inferiore
nucleo si ho capito c'è praticamente ho
tentato di disattivare gli androidi
perché non era sparito aliena brevi
servono a distruggere qualsiasi forma di
vita ce la faremo ad arrivare al punto
senza accuse si trova o mio dio mio dio
lega prega fermi e natale ho trovato una
roba licosa ascolta zio posso testarla
un ottimo non ti dispiace non funziona
per minati perché voglio riprovarci un
attimo forse adesso è morto kay ragazzi
ci dovremmo essere al reattore adesso
che sarebbe un punto dove mi dicono di
andare perché non c'è qualcosa che non
va guarda che non ho capito
un'altra arma le mie armi sì c'è godo a
volte mi torna al suo giusto per capire
un attimo di che si tratta di qua salva
la partita devo salvare ok perfetto
fatemi salvare perché mi chiama è un
budget è un po più bellissimo ragazzi ha
messo la pistola al posto della testa
rabellino com'è possibile allestire
raggi ragazzi mettete mette tre pistole
nelle green nei telefoni bene funziona è
la madonna non crea quel signore ci
dovrebbe essere il problema che figo est
opposto a raffica tapas e comunque è
quella la porta ci siamo ragazzi basta
non ne posso più ricorre in solita merda
di nave comunque era veramente figo è
bello complimenti reazione di
manutenzione o perfetto ci ho messo anni
per arrivare a questo posto ancora altri
ascensori perfetto già il circo lapis
ovviamente se non va bene se invece la
pista usava proprio lanciafiamme
direttamente bellissimo che è bello che
dio no a vigo sì ma un po di bianco io
alle pareti lo darei è però a me non sta
messo molto bene studi my hand sono
tutti qui sono tutti che cosa ma era la
zona di alien prima che aliena andasse a
[ __ ] in poche parole fermi un attimo
ma cos'era è saltato un ragno in faccia
mi è saltato ragni in faccia ti brucio
la nonna gli brucia è morto è morto
non è morto non è morto un cazzo vuol
dire ma le rouge astronomo e morirà così
credo morto sì c'è melo pupi madonna
quanto chi schiaccia che schifo e regala
non so non ho neanche capito cosa stiamo
facendo
basta che esplode al suo posto e siamo
contenti non ho capito bene che cosa sta
succedendo ma se mi spunta varagnolo
pesto è vivo e vivo questa merda ma non
ci crederò mai non ci crederò mai bene
dai per favori su ricordo ragazzi
concluso che l'episodio al prossimo di
halimi selection sarà l'ultimo in
assoluto parte tutto ragazzi spero che
video vi sia piaciuto come saito ragazzi
se il pd l'ha cresciuta stato mente mi
piace anche a faccia di facebook che
cosa non è vietata la trascrizione se
dovessi di sky ci vediamo un prossimo
video e le ragazze